comme tous les états du monde le japon
tente de se protéger face à la
propagation du coronavirus sur son sol
jeudi le premier ministre japonais
annonce et des mises en quarantaine de
14 jours pour toutes les personnes
arrivant dans l'archipel ayant récemment
séjourné en corée du sud ou en chine
pour prévenir la propagation des
maladies infectieuses et répondre aux
préoccupations des japonais nous allons
renforcer nos quarantaine à
l'immigration concernant ces deux pays
nous leur demanderons de rester deux
semaines dans des endroits désignés et
de ne pas utiliser les transports en
commun dans le pays
tous deux proches de washington séoul et
tokyo entretiennent depuis plusieurs
décennies des relations tendues en
raison de contentieux territoriaux et
historique
la corée du sud a décidé de protester
contre ces mesures qu'elle estime
irrationnel le pays veut aussi faciliter
le retour de ses ressortissants vivant
au japon
[Musique]
en réponse à la demande du gouvernement
japonais pour que les sud-coréens soient
mises en quarantaine pendant 14 jours
dans des endroits désignés à compter du
9 mars
le gouvernement sud-coréen imposera une
procédure d'immigration spéciale à tous
les ressortissants étrangers en
provenance du japon
la décision de prendre ou non des
mesures renforcées dépendra de la
gravité de la propagation du virus au
japon canada avec près de 6300 qu'à la
corée du sud est actuellement le
deuxième pays le plus impacté par
l'épidémie du coronavirus derrière la
chine
jusqu'à aujourd'hui une quarantaine
d'états et territoires ont interdit
l'entrée sur leur sol de personnes ayant
récemment séjourné en corée du sud
une vingtaine d'autres comme le japon
ont mis en place des mesures de
quarantaine
[Musique]